we may be getting closer to that sweet
ps5 release window but there's still a
lot of fun to be had on ps4
if you are a ps plus subscriber and want
to know what you can grab for free in
august
i've got you covered here's the new game
lineup for the month
first up is call of duty modern warfare
2 campaign remastered and it's exactly
what the name
says a remastered version of the 2009
shooters campaign
with memorable missions like cliffhanger
the only easy day
and the infamous no russian there is no
multiplayer included but hey warzone is
free to play if you want it
the second ps plus game is all about
multiplayer
fall guys pits 60 players against each
other in a series of challenges to
whittle down the crowd to a single
champion
think battle royale meets wipeout fall
guys is actually making its debut on ps
plus
so if you're not a subscriber you'll
have to shell out 20 bucks to get the
game
and those are your free playstation plus
games for august cod will be available
on july 28th
and fall guys is coming august 4th both
will be available until august 31st
stay tuned as we report on the new ps
plus lineup every month
[Music]
you